thank you might have noticed I'm Gavin
dowdy I'm an engineer on the AdWords
mobile app at the Google office in Los
Angeles I've been working with flutter
for about the last year and I'm here to
tell you something about it I'm going to
show you how the flutter SDK works
really well if you're building a
reactive application I'm going to show
you how it's programming language dart
gives you some really good core language
level primitives that you can build up
reactive data systems with and I'll show
you a few practical tips that we've
learned building an app with flutter
over the last few months I don't think
I'm gonna lose many of you guys but I
expect you to understand object-oriented
programming and know what a function is
particularly functions that can return
other functions and take functions as
parameters that's because I'm going to
show you a little bit of code in the
dart programming language I think he'll
find dart quite familiar but I'll try to
highlight the relevant parts as I go
along
now I've been at Google for about 11
years
I worked on the web for the first five
years and then I worked on native iOS
development around the same time I
started working on native iOS
development on things like Google+ and
Google Photos I also had a kid my
youngest kid around 2011 and you know I
always have some little hobby project
cooking on the side but when I had the
kid I was like totally busy I was just
like deja Fatherhood for several years
and it turned out these were these were
bad years to miss in web development I
wanted to get back into doing some some
hobby web projects just to experiment
with things let me show you the whole
testbed application I was using for this
amazing application it's a little
tic-tac-toe game that I was using to
figure out different web technology
stacks after being away for several
years and you know you can play a robot
AI and if you're on the internet you can
play a another person live over the
Internet so this is my testbed
application because what I was really
interested in was live data this idea
that data is going to be changing in
real time potentially by multiple users
so things like chat apps and
collaborative editor
in multiplayer games these are all kind
of live data applications and I thought
they were they were really interesting
and I wanted to have some some pretty
good tooling to start out with for a
live data and as I dug into the live
data I had this realization which that
is that come on all data is live data so
as programmers we like to lie to
ourselves and pretend that the data is
going to change when it is convenient
for us to have the data change but
inevitably we get it wrong you know
mountains crumble and stock market
prices fluctuate and your application
data changes somewhere on that spectrum
but you never get it right the first
time and if you don't design your
application for it right away at the
beginning you'll you'll be in for a lot
of trouble later when the the real-world
characteristics of the application
suggest it's can be changing on some
other time scale so I kind of missed out
what had happened in the front-end after
2011 when my kid was born and I came
back in and it's like wow all this stuff
has happened in such a short time you
know you not only to had things like web
components and service workers also web
pack and babble and it's like wow
there's just an explosion of
technologies to look at but there was
also this architectural sea change which
I'm sure you guys are all familiar with
by now and that is reactive programming
so I started looking at you know how
react worked and Elm and all of these
kinds of systems and they kind of blew
my mind because they were they aligned
really perfectly with this idea of your
data always changing so I kinda want to
share with you my little model of what I
would I consider the reactive
programming this is not particularly
original but you start with some piece
of state that's coming from you know all
the users in the world maybe and you
produce the state of your application
the UI renders that state to create a
view which the user then interacts with
to produce events that are combined with
the state to produce a new version of
the state and the cycle continues
now you can simplify this a little
further
just say the user is a pure function of
UI the users input the user function
input is the user interface and the
users output is a stream of events that
changed the state so I want to say like
hats up to Andre stalls for coming up
with that you should go watch his talk
and then this middle section when you're
rendering the state and when you're
handling the user input that that piece
is your reactive UI system and that was
the kind of that like the missing piece
that started the flood of being able to
reason about your application as this
flow of data so I'm working on this and
I'm having a lot of fun and I'm you know
doing this fluid development you know
and I'm talking about it at work a lot
and saying this is great this is amazing
but at work I'm still doing your classic
model-view-controller programming so I'm
sad but then my team lead comes up to me
and says you know I've been hearing you
talk about this reactive stuff for a
while I want you to take a look at this
flutter thing and see if we can use it
for our app and I started looking at
what flutter was and how it worked and I
realized that flutter one of the things
that was really designed to be was a
reactive UI system so happy Gavin so how
many of you heard of flutter before not
nearly enough
so mile-high overview kilometer height
overview since we're in Europe it's a
full application SDK you use the dart
programming language you use the flutter
SDK and the flutter API is to write your
application it gives you a really nice
developer ergonomics but you deliver an
arm binary image compiled machine code
application to both Android and iOS so
it's a cross platform SDK it's just the
same as you would if you were writing an
objective-c or Swift or C++ or something
it's got a really complete set of
widgets you generally don't have to
write your own widgets for the sort of
standard UI components they're very
complete but we don't pretend that there
isn't an underlying operating system so
there's a plugins interface that you can
use so you can take native code
and access platform level functionality
and you can also use code that you've
already written if you've got native
mobile code and finally it's a reactive
framework it uses the the reactive idiom
for rendering your user interface and a
lot of mobile development systems the
the code that is running when your
application runs you know there's
there's a fairly small percentage of it
that is accessible to you the engineer
you know you don't you don't really have
a lot of insight into how uikit renders
the views on iOS or you don't have you
don't have control of how the Dom itself
operates or how the compositor operates
or how the stylesheet system operates
you know you're using it through a
fairly small piece of that code is yours
flutter kind of flips it on its head
flutter starts with a very print
low-level primitive layer it's the text
rendering subsystem from Google Chrome
it's a very mature text rendering
subsystem it's multilingual and it does
nice fonts you know all of that good
stuff it uses the dart runtime VM and
libraries dart is a high-performance
language interpreter that was written by
some of the original engineers on the v8
interpreter team so it's a really kind
of a next-gen language and then it uses
skia which is a portable hardware
accelerated graphics layer and it does
the very primitive graphics operations
like bleeding and drawing lines and
filling and things like that so very low
level on top of that low level it's all
exposed as the dart UI package the rest
of flutter is built and that includes
not just what you'd expect
you know low-level primitives but all
the way up into the widget and styled
widgets system so everything that you
would normally think of as kind of
off-limits to you as an engineer is
available to you in flutter so you can
hook into it and unlike systems like
where you are programming in JavaScript
say and then you are driving the native
UI system with your code and pushing
code back and forth across a bridge to
the underlying platform UI system
flutter it keeps all of that code on
sort of its side of the wall so there's
no bridging and you get really good
performance that way now I was really a
you know excited to be able to build a
reactive system at work I was also
pretty skeptical that you'd be able to
get something that looked and felt nice
because a lot of the other
cross-platform systems I've used in my
career kind of always left me wanting a
little bit more but I did just what you
guys can do tonight is downloaded the
flutter SDK
I built the sample applications this is
one of them this is a gallery
application and I was like okay these
are great these were running at 60
frames a second you can do these really
nice designs and animations with it and
you know animated gifs don't actually
run at 60 frames a second so if you want
to get a feel for the the native look
and feel you can download the SDK if you
don't feel like downloading the SDK you
can actually download this app it's the
Hamilton app it's available in the App
Store since since we're not in the
States
Hamilton's one of our presidents there's
a really successful Broadway musical
production live musical production about
this guy it's a rap opera about
president Hamilton it's been selling out
for years now it's like completely sold
out theaters and they the producers of
the play contracted with a digital
agency in New York who wrote this
application using flutter and firebase
and it's the application you can use to
submit yourself to a lottery to win a
chance to spend hundreds of dollars for
a ticket to a Broadway show it's kind of
interesting because they didn't choose
either material design or iOS as their
UI metaphor so they've got more of a
branded UI experience and they found
that was very easy to develop with the
flutter system so why were we interested
in using flutter flutter wasn't even
officially in alpha release when we
started prototyping with it it is now
but we were particularly interested in
it for a few reasons one is we wanted a
reduced API surface like our team is
actually a fairly small team for like a
mainstream Google consumer facing
application and half of it was doing iOS
and half the team was doing Android
development and we liked each other just
fine
and we're using the same data sources
and stuff but we couldn't really share
code and we couldn't share expertise but
we did have to have the applications be
you know fairly identical on both
platforms so it was nice to say okay
great we're only gonna have one API to
target and it's not going to be iOS or
Android it's gonna be the flutter SDK
API you know similarly we were able to
say it's just gonna be this one language
so we can share some expertise and we
can share some code between ourselves
and we don't have to like be expert in
both Java and iOS and finally we had
quite a bit of existing dart code and
this is kind of a bonus a bonus round
here
there are a lot of a lot of dart code
running in production from major
applications inside of Google so we were
able to leverage some of that expertise
and some of that code but that's not
really required if you want to take
advantage of flutter I only mention it
because a lot of that code has been open
sourced so you're not you're not doing a
cold start you've actually got quite a
lot of libraries that are available dart
has a nice packaging system akin to NPM
so you can get a hold of these dart
packages and write your own but one of
the other major reasons we were
interested in using flutter was simple
developer happiness our large mobile
applications were taking several minutes
to compile you know you'd go and you'd
have to navigate to some subview and
like make sure that you've changed the
fonts or the spacing of the layout to be
correct for that view and if you didn't
you'd have to like rebuild and
reallocate down to that view and flutter
has hot reloading so as you might be
comfortable with from other environments
you can you can do this for like
high-performance native mobile
development as well and the nice thing a
couple of nice things about hot
reloading and flutter is the way the
system is architecture architected it
preserves state so you can hot reload in
under a second and it will preserve the
state of your application you see
there's a little counter number that and
forth and when they change the text it
will it will maintain the state another
nice thing about flutter hot reloading
is if you make an error you can you'll
see debug information for that widget
that had the error in it this particular
widget is taking up the whole screen but
it could be just some sub widget on your
UI and you'll see debug information
about the widget you can usually correct
it and reload again and it'll just keep
going so that's a really nice
productivity thing that's code isn't it
we're not seeing nearly enough code are
we so I started learning flutter just on
the flutter to write a prototype for our
app and I started right where you
probably will with widgets and widgets
are the overriding metaphor in flutter
so it's like files and the UNIX systems
so they're sort of a metaphor that's
used for things you wouldn't necessarily
expect them to be so everything in
flutter is a widget including things
like visuals styling and animation are
all widgets and you compose these
widgets and deep hierarchies of simpler
objects and the flutter runtime system
makes that efficient so let's take a
look at a really simple widget this is
like a labeled value it's got a label
it's got a value it's got some default
padding around it here's the source code
for that widget just a couple of things
it's got a couple of member variables
they're marked is final which would be
equivalent to like es6 Const
it's got a Const constructor which means
once you construct this object it's
never going to change
widgets are always immutable do I
default but you can even mark them
constitute a language level and then all
it's really responsible for is returning
a tree of other widgets that will then
be composed so this is this is maybe
equivalent to a pure functional react
component you know if you want to expand
this the padding you could just
introduce a padding widget around
everything else so it gives you a single
model a single semantic model for doing
your styling as well as rendering your
UI if you do have state like this this
nice material design slider that's
dragging back and forth it has some
state which is the current position of
the slider in numeric space and then
that that floating-point value is being
rendered in a label so this is called a
stateful widget a state for which it
doesn't produce the render method
directly it produces an object called a
state object that then implements the
the render method state objects stick
around between widget rebuilds so the
state and this object is just a value as
a floating point value and when you
implement the build method now in your
state object the state keeps building
this widget tree you can use that value
so it keeps the the stateful value of
your widget together with the code that
builds the UI and that's actually all
that flutter provides at a conceptual
level it's got a really rich library of
these things that do a lot of stuff for
you but that's really what you need to
know to get started building so knowing
this and having worked a little bit with
react and redux on my hobby projects i
built a prototype in a couple of months
and i want to tell you though most of
that time was doing application
infrastructure work to you know be able
to use it from dart and to be you know
work with our build system and stuff
there's a lot of kind of heavyweight
infrastructure at Google for writing
these super scalable applications with
really large teams the flutter part was
kind of the fun lightweight part and
here's a little screenshot of the the
application that the prototype
application you see like the animations
are pretty smooth and UI looks pretty
nice because I'm using the
out-of-the-box flutter widgets and it's
actually making a live data query
against our production servers it's a
fake account so that's nobody's real
data by the way so how do I build the
prototype I started with the
out-of-the-box widgets I use the core
library for HTTP to do the networking to
do authenticated HTTP fetches against
our production servers I used the Google
authentication plug-in so if you want to
have your users authenticate to their
Google services you would use the same
plug-in that I did for the prototype and
it you know it pulls up the permissions
page that they have to agree to and all
of that you don't have to write any of
that stuff yourself you just get the the
correct token back and I used a redox
datastore I used a ported Redux called
green cat and that worked just fine it
worked just like you'd expect it to so
this was convincing enough we decided we
would start work on a production version
of our application using flutter but one
thing they became pretty obvious to us
is that we had some complicated
asynchronous logic going on so I only go
into detail for a second about
this table view you can say it'll resort
when you click on one of these column
headers you can scroll past the
currently loaded page of data and just
keep scrolling and eventually when you
stop scrolling it'll load the next page
of data so you can quit down to these
ends of these multi thousand line lists
and it will it'll fetch extra data for
you and it will also filter by that date
range at the top it'll filter your
queries by that date range and all of
these user interactions and all these
network interactions you know are fairly
complicated to coordinate and we looked
at a bunch of solutions for this and
what we decided to use was observables
so there's a port of the observables
library it only took about 100 lines of
code to do that that's blurred out
because it's you know not open source
code but that's really about what the
code looked like to do all of those
interactions with that table and all
that complicated async logic that's a
like a snippet a readable snippet of it
but you can see it's it's very similar
to how you would chain operations on
collections and JavaScript some say it's
just very straight line and you're
declaring a lot of interaction this is
taking the the virtual list scroll index
that that list is virtualized so it's
not doing a lot of extra work that's not
on screen and using the observable for
the scroll position of the list to drive
the creation of a network RPC request
that asks for a specific page of data so
it's doing kind of a lot of work but
it's all kind of packaged up in this
nice declare it's too much that's too
complicated isn't it we're gonna do this
widget instead of that list so I can
show you what observables look like when
you're coding this is just a button as
you get a bunch of clicks on the button
and you add them up and render it inside
the button so it's just a link riman
encounter these are all kind of trivial
examples in there and it's overkill
sometimes to use streams but it's easy
to illustrate this this is gonna use the
scan operator from our X from the
observables library this is a little
animated rx marbles diagram of how the
scan operator works it basically takes
the last value produced by the stream
and the new value and runs a function on
them and outputs the results of that
function
so this is all the code that you would
need to do to implement a stream of this
incrementing value based on clicks on
the button you could you know you see
it's creating a new observable from the
stream of clicks and it's running the
scan operator on it with this
accumulation function you can even play
coke off on it a little bit and inline
the accumulation function because we've
got some pretty compact FATA or syntax
for defining functions so observables
are just transforms on this data flow
and if you want to make your own
observables or if you want to be able to
read the observables library in Dart
what you can use is the core dart
streams library so let's take a couple
minutes and look at streams this is kind
of a contrived example but again it's
this stream of clicks on a button down
at the bottom you can see you can
subscribe to that stream of clicks and
then call set state with an incrementing
counter values so this is this is the
state of a stateful widget calling set
state so it'll be rearend 'red and
here's here's how you build the button
they're just mapping the unpressed
handler to push the number one into this
stream so the input stream that the that
you're starting with is 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 11
asynchronously from the user and then
they're being added up and there is a
member variable getting updated so I can
call set state with it but that feels
kind of non-functional to me so you
which can do is you can move it into
like a local variable and then use it
inside of the stream map operator so
this is just like map on an array except
instead of processing all the values in
the array it's processing them as they
come in as they arrive and then I'm just
calling this local closure that's
incrementing the counter value and
returning a stream of that value but I'm
not calling set state because what
flutter gives you out of the box is this
the stream builder widget and that's a
generic widget that you can include and
it takes the stream that's producing
some value and a build function that
takes that value
and you takes a snapshot of the latest
version of that value and lets you build
your UI using that value so you don't
have to hold on to the state in your
stateful widget you just have to use a
string builder widget and that will also
take care of subscribing and
unsubscribing to the stream and calling
set state for you so it's really the way
to go if you're doing stateful UI if you
look at this map function a little bit
it's just a transform on the stream so a
map is implemented with transform
transforms and an interface you can
implement yourself there's a handy
stream transform operator here I'm not
going to go into this too much except to
say you could make a generic helper
function it takes parameterised types so
you don't have to work on integers like
I'm doing in this example and if you
look at this implement implementation
you can see it's basically calling a
reducer function with a state in action
which is the core of how redux does its
thing in addition to being almost almost
all of redux right here you get this is
pretty much literally the implementation
of the scan operator in the RX
observables library that you get with rx
start if you're using rx dart
observables are subclass from stream so
you can pass one directly to the stream
builder widget and that's what we're
doing with a lot of our our code so how
are we using flutter in our production
app well the first thing is we have a
lot of business objects that represent
kind of complex data flows and and user
interactions and network requests and
we're modeling those things as
essentially named collections of streams
and sinks a sink is just how you input a
value into the stream so the public API
for a business object would be you know
you put a value in here and then there's
a stream that you could subscribe to
that might represent the results of
taking that value in making a net
request and transforming the data to
make it convenient for rendering so and
that connection is actually made using
our observables so the implementation of
connecting the input sink to the output
stream is through some arbitrarily
complicated stream chain of observables
so we're using the observables library
ourselves
also using the native streaming library
it sort of depends on the use case we're
using plugins we're not just using
plugins because we want to access
certain platform functionality we do but
we also have quite a lot of native
libraries that we've already implemented
for Android on and iOS for like that
have comparable functionality for
example first-party authentication is a
plug-in and there's Android and iOS
implementations that we're wrapping up
as a plug-in so we can use it in our
application without having to write all
is kind of complicated and maybe legally
significant code to make sure we're
authenticating people correctly we're
using a lot of fluttered widgets we're
contributing widgets back to flutter
there was an engineer on our sister team
who wrote an autocomplete widget that's
going into the main flutter library and
that's because we're relying on all of
you there's there's quite an ecosystem
of reactive tooling already not all of
it is written by Googlers there's the RX
dart library that you can use if you're
into immutable immutable j/s immutable
values I encourage you to take a look at
the Bilt value library that uses some
really slick dart code generation which
is a whole other topic but it makes it
very easy for you to say to define a
complicated structure of immutable
objects and then efficiently produce new
versions of that based on your your
desired mutations and then there are
redox implementations so this is the one
you should use
it's the the public Dart Redux
implementation there is a flutter
companion package these guys are
building out these are not Google
employees but they're building out the
the redox an ecosystem for you so you
can hook up to a Redux store with
flutter with a minimum of boilerplate so
go to and I just want to wrap this up
and say you've seen how like
applications might want to respond to
data that changes on some unpredictable
schedule you can use observables to get
a powerful vocabulary for declaratively
describing how you want to react to
these
things you can use dart streams if you
want a little more low-level power I
think you know dart streams is going to
continue to add things and maybe and
maybe get up to parity with observables
so you just use them directly and you
can hook it all into flutter pretty
trivially flutter is designed to work
with data that's going to be changing
rapidly so you can take all of your
reactive development expertise and start
right away with flutter you don't have
to like reinvent your your mental model
of how this stuff works you could just
use mine if you've got any questions
about flutter if you download the SDK
and play with it and have problems with
it you can ask me anything tomorrow at
2:30 there's also a talk about Rx
tomorrow at 5:30 so you want to really
deep dive and observables if you want to
learn more about our X you can go to
reactive xio
if you want to have some those cool
marble diagrams there rx marbles comm
you can learn more about dart at
dartlang.org one of the cool things they
have on that site is an interactive
browser-based repple for the dart
language so you can just pull it up in
your browser and try out code snippets
in dart and it has a sharing
functionality we use it all the time we
like hey how'd you code this up in dart
and you like well you could try this or
you could try that and you could send a
link to somebody it's really really
handy and finally if you wanna learn
more about flutter you can go to flutter
io and get the link to download the SDK
for your platform as well as a lot of
really good polished documentation and
API Docs and so forth oh okay all right
I'm John so thank you very much